welcome back to this special edition of
hannity
while the covet 19 virus has largely
spared children
the lockdowns put in place because of it
have had
devastating effects on their learning
social development
and their well-being kids in some areas
have been locked out of their classrooms
for
months and with the delta variant
spreading
the american federation of teachers
president randy weingarten
suddenly can't guarantee that schools
will reopen in the fall
some places are making the in-person
return harder
for example in los angeles public
schools all
students and teachers will have to be
coveted tested
at least once a week vaccinated or not
but in the free state of florida
governor ron desantis has just issued an
executive order banning mass mandates in
schools
he says parents should be the ones
deciding if their kids
wear masks this comes as texas governor
greg abbott
yesterday signed an executive order that
bans city and local governments
from requiring vaccines or mass mandates
including public schools here now with
reaction are fox news contributors sean
duffy
and leo tyrell thank you both uh leo
all things california all vaccines all
the time no matter where you are indoors
outdoors breathing the fresh air up by
mammoth that doesn't matter they want
you
to be masked and they want you to be
tested
how's it flowing for you there again
we're going to get you out of there
it's flowing horrible it's flowing
horrible jason
and that's why i applaud florida and
texas with a two million dollar gift to
gavin newsom
from the teachers union they are making
it almost impossible
for kids to go to school we're less than
two weeks away
they are now demanding either you get
vaccinated
and tested even if you're vaccinated
test it the thing that hurts me
the most you know the democrats talk a
good game about helping people of color
they are wrecking the lives of young
people of color
by denying them education the teaching
you you do not want to go back to school
jason
they want to earn their paycheck from
home and they're trying to provide an
incentive
to do in-line or online training that's
why
randy weingarten said she couldn't
commit to force to end training or in
classroom training it's a sham
and it's very very hurtful for people of
color
yeah and people of color and our kids
they they don't put kids first
now sean duffy you and i got to serve in
congress together we also got to serve
with a guy named ron desantis who was
he's a pretty good member of congress
but he's a really good governor if you
ask me
and um he's he's out there doing some
things texas is doing some things with
this radical idea that
parents should make the decision about
whether or not
their kids wear masks is that the right
policy yeah
i'm not right first the next time we see
leo on tv and other californians these
will be wrapped in saran wrap or bubble
wrap that's the next phase we're going
to go to in california
they're so crazy but thank god for texas
and and in florida you know ron desantis
with this concept of subsidiary
we want we want decisions made at the
most local level possible right
and ron de santa stepped in as the
governor and stopped school boards and
cities from putting mass mandates in
place
but what ron realized was that parents
are the most local place possible where
these decisions should be made they
should decide whether the kids go to
school what they mask or not
that's called freedom right that's i
love that i mean this is this is why
elections have consequences and it's so
great that ron desantis is there but
here's what concerns me about this
when when randy weingarten the head of
the teachers union says we're going to
try to reopen schools
let's interpret that to mean they're
going to do everything they can
to make sure our schools are shut down
they don't care about our kids they
don't care about their education or
their health or seeing smiles and how to
read smiles on people's face
they care about the union so listen we
have to ban the union we have to
we have to dismantle the teachers union
and what concerns me as
a parent of nine kids that i send my
kids
eight hours a day to be taught by these
looney tunes who are anti-science and
anti-child
what the heck are they being taught
these are crazy people that we send our
kids to every day
school choice is the answer and by one
last point to
to what leo said the poor kids minority
kids are getting hurt by these policies
because if you have money
you are sending your child to a school
in person learning it's a charter school
it's a parochial school
you are getting an education for your
kids but if you don't have the money
because you're in the inner city and
you're poor
your kids are stuck at home on zoom and
not learning anything
yeah and you hope they're paying
attention to zoom now leo
what's wrong with self-determination
what is what is the argument supposedly
against
allowing a parent to make decisions i
thought the democrats were the one who
would say
my body my choice i i i don't hear him
saying that about this
uh you know what i'll tell you the
democratic party jason has been hijacked
the last eight years as far as what what
sean was talking about freedom liberty
that's the american way
the democrats and we're in the bluest
state i'm in
i don't want to use the inappropriate
word i am in the worst state in the
country
and the bottom line is the progressive
wing of the democratic party
has hijacked the educational system the
justice system
and it is horrible here that's why we
have a recall election
in california the freedom is in texas
and florida
sean uh what what are we going to do
what should parents do i mean
you're up in wisconsin i'm in utah not
everybody lives in florida
or what what do you think parents should
do to gain control
but the evidence to leo's point is
people are leaving california in new
york and going to the states of freedom
that's why
you know you want to get a u-haul and
move to new york it's cheap you want to
get a u-haul and go from new york to
texas
it's really expensive because everyone
is moving there but jason you and i
follow politics and i think this is
interesting when you
have an open border or you want to tax
billionaires or you want the green new
deal
that really doesn't for a lot of people
affect them right they don't have the
effects of that policy
but you shut down schools or you make my
little first grader put on a mask for
eight hours a day
now you've you penetrated into my home
and there is a seething rage
i think with parents across this country
who want to make sure they're protecting
their little kids and they know the
teachers unions
fauci the cdc biden are not protecting
their kids or their education
and there is going to be a massive
political blowback and backlash
that's why i think republicans are going
to take control of the house for sure by
a big number
and i think very likely the senate as
well because americans want balance and
they want sanity for their kids and in
their government policies
and they want some data to back it up i
think americans would actually do things
that they believed in what was being
said to them
but you know what they don't and when
they allow these literally by the tens
of thousands people that cross their
borders
who we know have coveted a certain
percentage of map coping they don't have
masks
come on in leo that's i mean that's the
message in california more than anywhere
is doing that
it's a mixed message it's a wrong
message it's a misleading message
and it scratches the head of everyone
who lives in california they're
demanding
all these controls on american citizens
and they open the door
to illegal aliens who have coven who are
not wearing a mask
it doesn't make sense and i agree with
sean there's going to be a tsunami in
2022
we're going to retire nancy pelosi and
we're going to recall gavin newsom
yeah i i think the americans is fed up
with that they want to take control
i got a heart out sean i got to go
because more of this special edition of
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else